hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
PlayStation 4 exclusive have been
undeniably excellent for many years now
there's even more to come in the future
with the Last of Us part to death
stranding and Ghost of Tsushima but
right now it's the turn of days gone but
what are we to expect from this
post-apocalyptic tale here's 30 things
you should know about days gone let's
set the scene days gone is yet another
zombie apocalypse story well yes I know
we'll get to those scary boogers soon
but first let's get a handle on the main
star Deacon sent John if you've watched
Sons of Anarchy you'll already have a
great understanding of Deacons past he's
part of a motorcycle club
which is more like a family or a
brotherhood deacons life is then torn to
pieces when an infection hits the world
turning everyday people into ravenous
monsters two years later only a small
pocket of humanity has survived and
Deacon acts like a mercenary follows
people helping survivors in this new
world with his trusty fight for company
so I've said zombie a few times already
we need to get that straight I made the
mistake of calling the infected in the
game zombies and the developer was not
happy and quickly put me straight these
are free cos who are victims of the
infection which turns them into
flesh-eating carnivorous beasts but they
are not on debt the freaker's are alive
they have needs they eat they drink they
have sleep cycles they even migrate to
when the weather changes a key note to
make here is that freaker's are most
active at night so keep an eye out for
the Sun dropping in the distance and be
prepared let's break down those zombie
types we know so far sorry I mean
freakiest the majority of the Freak is
unknown as swamis humans who reached
adulthood before the infection hit they
have strength in numbers one or two
won't cause us issues but a few more
will quickly swarm in and overrun us if
enough fricos are in one group it
becomes a heart that's when you need to
run for your life screaming I'm speaking
of screaming they're here too these have
the ability to stun our character and
summon freaky hordes in earshot of your
location will also make breakers huge
hulking mutated freaker's with immense
strength and
harder to take down like tanks I guess
on the other side of the spectrum are
the newts these are children who are
infected physically they don't have the
strength of their adult counterparts and
mentally they don't have the confidence
they are timid and follow their prey
around waiting for the right moment to
strike should we become injured in game
the newts will be on the offensive
trying to finish it off for an easy meal
I found this fact really interesting
it's possible to see swarmers and other
types of freaker's attacking newts the
freaker's are trying to survive stay
alive so they'll do that any way they
can and everyone needs to eat oh and if
you think this is ambience crowd break
is confined to the human race
think again so far we've seen infected
Ravens wolves and even this big son of a
bear expect to discover different
tactics for each encounter with the
infected the day's gun team are keeping
some mutations of the virus secret so
expect the unexpected
as more enemy types are revealed the
longer you play but of course the
infected our only one potential threat
on your travels the good old human race
remained the real problem with this
world outlaws and bandits rule the
lawless Luntz gang culture takes
precedent survival of the fittest in
full swing
the rippers are a group of enemies who
act like a cult praising the freakiest
as the next step of human evolution kind
of like the whisperers in The Walking
Dead but far more active and loud from
afar they actually look like freaker's
which can give you a fright if they pull
out a gun and start shooting
there are also Marauders and rival gangs
and settlements to attend with some are
militarized others are scavengers almost
all are hostile and we'll look to ambush
deacon in the opportune moments like a
rope to almost Decapitator x' if we
aren't paying attention the world itself
is completely open to us which makes our
motorcycle so very important
the devs describe the bike as a
character and a tool we won't be
throwing it away when we find another
this motorcycle is our motorcycle it
means a great deal to deacon this is
where a great game mechanic comes in the
motorcycle is upgradable it can be
improved incrementally upgrading the
saddlebags will allow us to carry more
items and
are the bike parts give additional
stability similarly we'll be taking care
of the bike maintaining it on the road
otherwise it's walking on foot and I've
heard it's pretty dangerous out there
something as menial as visiting a gas
station can be life or death from other
groups as you're not the only person
looking for it on a quick note nitrous
boosting is possible the narrative and
story beats in days gone have been given
extra attention learning from the
brilliance of the last of us
storytelling and horizon zero dawn
civility to make the player care
unreservedly for the main protagonist
days gone does the same in its own
unique way using flashbacks to break up
the modern day carnage to tell us more
about deacon and his family in the first
hour you'll see Deacon as a young
bachelor helping his future wife at the
roadside these small but meaningful
scenes help us understand what makes
Deacon tick his loyalty he's caring his
love of the open road everything feeds
back into modern day Deacon deacons
personal triumphs and losses impact him
and the future he tries to strive for to
simplify this we may be playing as a man
who kills thousands of free Keys and
Marauders but he wasn't this man before
the outbreak if story in videogames is
your back days gone has got you covered
another thing you're probably here for
guns lots of guns that he's gone is
packed to the nines with weapons we've
already seen pistols shotguns assault
rifles SMGs sniper rifles crossbows axes
sledge hammers baseball bats and knives
and if you're a sadist who likes to hurt
digital people in multiple ways days
gone I've got your back to lead on from
this the crafting system takes
scavenging to the next level we've seen
Deacon make a bomb with an air bag and a
few other items he's turned engine parts
into silences for weapons and as the
story progresses Deacon will have access
to other items to help craft molotovs
and improve the weapons he has in his
possession the crafting system takes
every inspiration from the last of us
which at the time was praised hugely
how do you like to play your video games
do you like stealth our all-out action
tactics are downright aggression in days
gone it's your choice if you want to sit
back and watch enemy patrol patterns
before taking them out silently go for
it if you want to set up explosives and
lead freaker's through them you can do
that too
if you prefer to run and gun then the
combat focus mechanic will be invaluable
to you
Deakin can slow down time kinda like
that scene in Red Dead Redemption design
up shots when things become too hectic
everyone loves a little bit of bullet
time thank you so much Max Payne the
developers Sony Bend have talked openly
about the dangerous open world and
stated that any second you may be
attacked the feeling of anxiety is
palpable over many years on behalf
become a minor inconvenience in video
games well not anymore
days gone brings the terror back through
the freaker's and other dynamic events
like we've seen you could be riding
happily down the road and be carotid by
a trap or even set upon by wolves the
events change and randomize to keep us
on our toes and remember if your bike
runs out of fuel you'll be stranded
pretty damn nerve-wracking the open
world is filled with checkpoints safe
houses fast travel points and camps some
camps are friendly such as Manny's camp
who is essentially deacons mechanic when
bike upgrades are needed but not all
camps are filled with nice folk some are
aggressive
some are standoffish some shoot before
they speak and some are surrounded by
freaker's the camp's themselves once
cleared are safe and can be used for
rest as we already know the freaker's
are particularly strong and active
throughout the night we could simply go
to sleep and get back on the road when
your daylight hits
the camps are predominantly here for
upgrades and item purchasing using two
types of credit line camp credits and
Trust credits credits are earned by
helping each community if they are in
fear of an enemy encampments go
eliminate it if they lose a member of
their community
step up you'll be rewarded out in the
open world freaking nests are in
abundance as freaker's are living they
need a home they can be anywhere and
everywhere when you see one burn it but
be prepared because if their home
they'll be slightly annoyed keep
destroying these nests to receive fast
travel points as this is an open-world
game
they'll be invaluable as this is a ps4
exclusive photo mode has been confirmed
four days gone it has a few extra layers
to play around with but ultimately is
the same as the photo mode in other ps4
games a quick point about the user
interface it's a work of art days gone
moves away from the blocky menu seen in
99% of other games and tries to do
something different I know this isn't
huge but it's so good it deserves
noticing days gone we'll take the
average gamer around 30 hours to
complete with additional time to find
all those collectibles for the platinum
trophy which looks very achievable
trophy hunters there is over six hours
of cutscenes to discover - so grab some
popcorn days gone has multiple versions
to choose from and good old pre-order
bonuses pre-order before the game
releases to receive instant bike
upgrades for speed defense and trouble
and early access to the drift of
crossbow all these items and upgrades
are available in-game but of course will
take us a little bit more time to unlock
in terms of versions of days gone you
have a few to choose from the base game
is always a good option but there's also
a digital deluxe edition which comes
with music and an art book three bike
skins early access to the monkey wrench
skill and the ps4 dynamic theme physical
versions include the special edition
with all the previous items but in real
life you can touch it with your hands
and finally the collector's edition has
everything we've mentioned plus a patch
for a biker jacket for decals six
collectors pin badges and a statue of
deacon looking like he's going to drop
the best rap album of the apocalypse and
that's everything 30 things you should
know about days gone oh one more thing
actually days gone releases on April
26th worldwide that's a Friday if you
need to take a day off work off pretend
to be on weld to get the day off school
your secret is safe with me
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade it's
been an absolute pleasure I'll see you
next time
you